on mettra pas à priori nos enfants à
l'école sur la base du volontariat
je comprends kahn et qu'il puisse
vouloir le faire nous on n'est pas
favorable en tout cas non je suis pas
inquiète toutefois j'attends de voir
c'est tout le monde il y va parce que là
vraiment si tout le monde y va il sont
tous vraiment il ya un élève à côté
d'autres dans des fins voilà à ses
proches
j'attends de voir a priori on en veut
dire qu'on va les laisser y aller et
puis surtout qu'ils sont très impatients
nos enfants quand on est à l'école on
voit ça plutôt plutôt positivement voit
la commission qui veut démanteler les
conditions soient bien réunies
logistiquement parlant pour que pour que
ça se passe sereinement pour tout le
monde on verra d'ici là ce qui se passe
quelle sera la situation sanitaire en
france est à paris et puis quels seront
les les précautions qu'on pourra mettre
en place dans les écoles est accordée
aux enfants ma soupe à distance la par
rapport à l'autre dans dans les classes
cantine ou pas ou petit frichti dans le
sac
voilà après je pense que il faut être
prêt à tout je pense que la distance
dans les classes ou dans la cour de
récréation ça va être compliqué donc il
ya plusieurs avis moi personnellement on
va attendre faire la première semaine
voir comment ça s'est passé voir s'il ya
un vrai intérêt aussi à les envoyer
parce que si c'est pour avoir des demi
journées ou des cours un peu haché au
final nous depuis qu'on est en
confinement à la pas mal de fait on fait
tout les classes à la maison et voilà
elle fait plusieurs heures chaque jour
on est au final assez productif on verra